Він не лише свідок, а й важливий підозрюваний.
Україна не дотримала обіцянки.
Дуже болісний результат.
7 вересня були звільнені 35 українців - бранців Кремля.
В Україні їхнє звільнення викликало велику радість,
однак у багатьох постало питання про ціну цього обміну.
Чи була політична ціна цього обміну
виправданою? Про це ми говоримо
з євродепутаткою Каті Пірі.
Саме вона є авторкою листа до президента України Зеленського
з проханням не видавати Росії Володимира Цемаха,
який є свідком у справі збиття MH17.
Пані Пірі, після цього обміну багато європейських політиків
говорили про нову надію на вирішення конфлікту.
Росія відпустила лише тих людей, яких вона вже давно мала би відпустити.
Як Ви вважаєте, було це шантажем України Росією чи Ви також поділяєте нову надію?
Звісно, ми всі хочемо, аби кровопролиття припинилося,
тож усе, що може наблизити мир для українців, дуже важливе.
Але ми бачимо, що серед  в'язнів, яких обміняли, українці - це політичні в'язні.
А серед росіян є ті, хто справді робив щось хибне та незаконне
на території України, тож, звичайно,
не можна сказати, що одна група в'язнів така сама, як інша.
Кожне людське життя є однаково цінним.
Але якщо ми говоримо про політичну ціну,
чи вважаєте Ви цей обмін рівноцінним?
Ні. Я - євродепутатка з Нідерландів.
Бачити, що ключова особа для Москви,
яку передали Росії під час цього обміну полоненими,
- це громадянин України, який є не лише свідком,
але й важливим підозрюваним у збитті MH17,
- це, якщо чесно, дуже болісний результат,
особливо для Нідерландів та для всіх родичів жертв MH17.
Іноді Цемаха називають свідком, іноді - підозрюваним.
Чи знаєте Ви напевно, що він має статус підозрюваного?
Спершу Міжнародна слідча група сприймала його як свідка,
а нідерландський прокурор написав у листі, що,
виходячи з нової інформації, яка з'явилася цього літа,
тепер він - один із підозрюваних.
Чи вважаєте Ви, що Україна заплатила надто високу ціну за цей обмін?
Абсолютно! З міжнародної точки зору
Україна також має зобов'язання забезпечити співпрацю
всіма можливими способами для того,
аби знайти відповідальних за збиття MH17.
Передавши Росії одного з підозрюваних,
Україна не дотримала цієї обіцянки.
Я розумію, наскільки обмін полоненими був важливим для людей в Україні.
Я це розумію, адже саме в цьому парламенті
ми дали Олегу Сенцову премію Сахарова.
Проте ця ціна була надзвичайно високою,
особливо для тих людей, які хочуть знайти справедливість щодо збитого літака.
Чи погіршить передача Володимира Цемаха Росії відносини ЄС-Україна?
Адже Нідерланди - член Євросоюзу.
Буду дуже відвертою.
З одного боку, всі хочуть, аби цей конфлікт вирішили.
І ми всі розуміємо, що український народ хоче
повернення українських політв'язнів.
Це має цілковиту підтримку як Європейського Союзу, так і мою особисто.
З іншого боку, не можна обмінювати одне на інше.
Не можна ставити жертв MH17 на другорядне місце,
а саме це сталося під час обміну полоненими.
Але чи можете Ви сказати, що відносини між ЄС і Україною погіршаться?
Із приводу цього в нас будуть серйозні розмови з керівництвом України.
Я впевнена, що вони вже відбуваються.
Є думка, що після передачі Цемаха Росії санкції,
запроваджені Євросоюзом проти Росії,
можуть послабити чи скасувати. Чи є така вірогідність?
Ми знаємо, що в ЄС є країни, які хотіли б скасування санкцій щодо Росії.
Але давайте дивитися на обмін позитивно.
До певної міри видається, що керівництво Росії
готове почати говорити про те, як вирішити цей конфлікт.
Цемаха не треба було видавати Москві.
Але якщо залишити це в стороні, то попереду ще дуже довгий шлях.
Цей конфлікт складний, із дуже багатьма жертвами.
Дуже багато людей загинули, зокрема громадяни України, які воювали в ньому.
Це буде непросто врегулювати.
Я поки що не побачила позитивних сигналів з Москви, аби скасовувати санкції.
Ви є авторкою листа президенту України Зеленському.
Чи отримали Ви відповідь або реакцію на нього від української сторони?
Листа - ні. Але реакція до певної міри надійшла наступного дня.
Я маю на увазі, що Цемах, на наш превеликий жаль,
виявився учасником обміну полоненими.
Українська сторона заявила, що Цемаха допитали.
Чи нідерландська сторона брала в цьому участь?
Я лише знаю те, що повідомляли в нідерландських ЗМІ.
Як ви розумієте, це юридичний процес, тож
ми намагаємося не політизувати роботу цієї важливої слідчої групи.
У нідерландських газетах писали, що слідчі мали дві нагоди допитати Цемаха.
Але ми також знаємо, що минулого тижня нідерландська прокуратура попросила
зробити його доступним для допитів ще й у майбутньому.
Тепер це вже неможливо.
Думаю, цим обміном полоненими
Москва насправді визнає свою провину у збитті MH17,
роблячи такий великий наголос на обміні за участю Цемаха.
Зараз Цемах у Росії. Що робитиме уряд Нідерландів з цього приводу?
Як ми знаємо, Росія не лише не співпрацює зі слідством,
вона ще й заперечує будь-яку причетність до того, що сталося.
Хоча ми маємо багато фактів, наданих
не політиками, а прокуратурою, які демонструють,
що Росія була значною мірою причетна до збиття MH17.
Із чотирьох ключових підозрюваних
троє мають російське громадянство і лише один - українське.
Певна річ, ми можемо попросити Росію надати Цемаха для допиту.
Але ми не наївні.
Москва не наголошувала б так на тому,
щоб його доставили до Росії, якби хотіла,
щоб він був доступним для допитів Міжнародною слідчою групою.
Я боюся, що щонайменше Цемаха вже ніколи не буде в суді як свідка.